another 569 people have lost their lives
bringing the total number of deaths now
to two thousand nine hundred and twenty
one thirty three thousand seven hundred
and eighteen people have now tested
positive for the disease two thousand
six hundred ninety eight deaths have
occurred in England one hundred and
seventeen have been recorded in Wales
and 126 in Scotland let's talk to our
correspondent Peggy Spencer who is in
the newsroom as you see Katy welcome to
you and broad in line with yesterday's
figure but that was Sharpie up on the
day before yeah we are now seeing these
increases on a daily basis I would say
though that today's data isn't quite as
sobering as the set of data that we
received yesterday with those increases
that we saw yesterday so we have a quick
talk through some of the figures so if
we take firstly the figures for the
whole of the UK and it's worth noting
that actually a more astute among you
might realize that if you put the
figures together for Scotland Northern
Ireland Wales and England they don't
actually add up to the UK figure that's
because of the varying ways that they're
recorded between the different countries
so the UK figure comes from the
Department of Health and they have a
different time we've noticed in the the
last couple of days actually they seem
to lag slightly behind on the figures
for Scotland and Northern Ireland so
that's perhaps why we're seeing
different sort of variations in
recording today but what the UK figure
shows us certainly is that there's been
an increase of deaths by 569 so now the
total for the UK is stands at two
thousand nine hundred and twenty one so
just slightly below three thousand now
looking at the wider picture four
confirmed cases thirty three thousand
seven hundred and eighteen again
yesterday we were talking about an
increase of almost four thousand today
again with this set of data were talking
about an increase of almost four
thousand so I think that will be
interesting to see what is said about
that of a Downing Street pressure a bit
later on to see whether or not that is a
perhaps a sign of flatter growth we
talked a few days ago at that press
conference about perhaps there were some
green shoots that the the confirmed
cases seem to be leveling off perhaps
the fact that we've got two days in a
row with four thousand just as an
increase for confirmed cases that could
be a good
sighing if we have a look regionally
take a look at what's going on in
Scotland deaths there have increased by
50 now
yesterday's figures showed an increase
in the number of people dying by 16
today that's gone up by 50 but in her
briefing Nicola Sturgeon was keen to
stress that that's down to the way that
this data has been recorded she said she
believes certainly the a total of 40 of
those deaths should actually have been
distributed across other days but it
came down to the fact that actually
family members weren't able to be
contacted in time so that is why she
says that figure is so high today for
Wales we've seen an increase in deaths
by 19 actually that's dropped slightly
and what we saw yesterday yesterday the
the number of deaths significantly rose
to 29 today it's down to death gan up
only by 19 if we look at the figures for
Northern Ireland an increase of 6
they're taking their total to 36 now and
if we have a look at England finally as
well deaths have increased by 561 in
England taking their total to 2698
public NHS England give us a few more
details exactly about some of the
information of those people that have
died we know they their ages ranged
between 22 and 144 of the 561 deaths
that were recorded had no underlying
health conditions I mean it is you can't
really draw too much into the figures at
this stage we know that there we are
going to see these exponential increases
it's going to a couple of weeks before
we see those lockdown measures taking
effect